هي احدى محطات توقف القوافل التجاريه
تاريخيه و بوابه دخول القادمين الى
السعوديه وشبه الجزيره العربيه محافظه
الاحساء الضاربه في عرض التاريخ اثرها
الكثيره شاهده دوما على عظمتها ففيها كانت
اوائل المستوطنات البشريه منذ العصر
الحجري ما جعلها بقعه تاريخيه مهمه في
تاريخ المملكه وفي قلب الاحساء يقف قصر
ابراهيم كاحد التحف المعماريه في المملكه
حيث يجمع تصميمه بين العرب والعسكري لكونه
احد اهم قواعد المنطقه وحميتها الاولى
الذي يعد اوائل المساجد التي بنيت في
المنطقه الشرقيه عائدا الى السنه السابعه
للهجره والى جانب الاثار التاريخيه تبدو
الاحساء كواحه مليئه بعيون مياه الطبيعيه
وهي اكثر من 100 عام من المياه اهمها
الجوهريه وان سابع والاخدود